What is up everyone? Welcome back to another episode
of Paragliding Out this podcast. I'm your host Aninder Singh, and
in case you haven't already done so, go do me a favour and smash
that like and subscribe button and drop in a rating wherever
possible. Because as mentioned earlier,
these small acts of kindness from your end help us go a long
way in reaching out to more pilots out there and eventually
making the community a safer and a more fun place to be.
Now, today's episode is based on my personal experience about
running this podcast. You know, the other day I was
reading a book called Start with Why.
It's written by Simon Sinek. And for those of you who haven't
heard of him, he's a pretty amazing writer and a speaker in
today's time. And this book is all about how
great leaders inspire everybody to take action.
And I thought that if I'm doing my own bit in the world of
paragliding, that I might as well put in my best foot forward
to make a change, right? So I've been trying to ruffle
through the pages of this book on and off various days.
And there's one thing that I found that when I read this book
early in the morning, it's almost that I can lock in and
focus in all my attention on absorbing whatever I was
reading. And this is very different from
picking up this book later on in the day.
For example, you know, when I'm taking a break from editing and
the admin work around the podcast, like let's say
somewhere in midday, it's so much more harder to focus.
And this got me thinking that why is it so much easier to
gather my thoughts and absorb everything so clearly first
thing in the morning? And more importantly, what if we
can replicate the state of mind during the art of flight when we
go out and fly our wings? I mean you don't be chasing
numbers during any regular cross country flight or be it while we
are racing against other pilots in APWC or let's say when we
have crucial decision making like when to go for the lead
points or which transitional lines to pick.
Like mental clarity is paramount in our sport.
So my curious mind got to work and I started digging the signs
behind it. And to my surprise, there's
actually a term for it and it's called as the perfect zone of
clarity. You know, The thing is, in the
mornings, our brain is chemically primed to perform at
its finest. There's no mental overload,
there are minimal distractions. And most importantly, The thing
is that we all go through a set of rituals.
I mean, consciously or subconsciously depends on the
person. But from waking up to achieving
this clarity, there's a set of events that happens in a
sequence and I'll walk you through what happens and why it
happens and most importantly, how we can achieve this clarity
on demand so that our subconscious and conscious minds
operate in perfect harmony when we need them the most.
You see, the first thing that happens is something known as
CAR and this is also called cortisol awakening response.
And I must clarify here that cortisol gets a bad repetition
amongst a lot of people because it is known as simply the
hormone which causes stress. But there's much more to it and
The thing is a little bit of cortisol is not that bad.
And that is exactly what happens.
First thing in the morning, there's a tiny bit of a surge in
cortisol level which acts as a natural wake up booster from our
body. It's basically like an alert
system which makes us ready to tackle the day and gives us the
energy for it. And then secondly, what happens
is that there's something known as morning light alignment.
And this is when the natural light starts entering our eyes
and this process when it hits the retina, it triggers the
release of serotonin and dopamine, you know, the famous
mood enhancing and focus enhancing hormones that we all
love. And then finally, there's this
thing called first moments and hydrations.
These are the initial steps that we take after we wake up, which
of course you know, there's a number brainer that they help
make our blood move in the body, which in turn sends more oxygen
to the brain. And then the first sips of water
that we take kind of restores the fluids and salts that we
have lost overnight. So all together these events
like the cortisol response, the light exposure and the movement
and hydration are essential in creating the peak clarity that
we get first thing in the morning and in paragliding.
Of course, mental clarity and physical readiness are both kind
of critical to maximize the performance out there.
So basically it boils down to mimicking these mental and
physical States and most importantly the psychological
triggers on demand as and when required.
And here's an interesting thing. When I was researching this, I
came across a study which said that top athletes like Formula
One drivers like Lewis Hamilton and a few other elite marathon
runners as well, they use this multi dimensional approach to
hit their peak zone no matter what time of the day they are
performing. So this is super interesting
because our goal is to simulate the brain chemistry and the
conditions of this sharp morning so that be it 10 AM or be it
3:00 PM, our mind is clear, focused and emotionally ready to
make it count. So here is how we bring this
routine on demand before we go out for a flight or chase
whatever is it that we wish for. Now the key here is to start
somewhere between 90 to 120 minutes.
So let's say 1 1/2 to 2 hours before we strap into our
harnesses. So the first thing that we need
to mimic is the light exposure. And the idea here is to try and
step into the natural sunlight. If you're already there, then
try and remove your sunglasses for a few minutes.
Like the whole point is to let the photons of natural light hit
our retina, which basically is essential in resetting the brain
and tricking our body into believing that it's going to be
go time pretty soon. Now one of the most important
parts is hydrating and smart snacking.
Now I'm using the word smart snacking because it's essential
to not have an overload of food before going out to perform
because what we are aiming for is a steady supply of fuel.
Something which has got a mix of carbohydrates and proteins.
Let's say for example peanut butter and banana.
Perfect amount of fats is heavy enough to give you a constant
energy source but not heavy enough to weigh you down.
Or oats or nuts like this is your own choice.
But the point here is to have a light snack which gives us a
constant source of energy over the next few hours to come.
The idea here is to not overly rely on caffeine because of
course energy drinks like Red Bull or any other like no hard
feelings against Red Bull regardless of the amount of
competitions, amount of crazy things that they do in the
competitions. But the point here is that if
you try and go in for a caffeine booster before you go out and
perform, there is a high time, which is going to come pretty
quickly because the amount of sugar that these energy drinks
have is pretty high. And then the crash that comes in
when your body is recovering from all the sugar rush, if it
happens mid flight, then it can turn counterproductive.
So instead of chasing liquid caffeine, I would rather say
that there's a sweet spot of somewhere around 300 to 500
milliliter of water so that we are able to replenish the fluids
and salt up to optimal levels so that when we go out, there's no
threat for dehydration. And now the point #3 is gentle
movement. And this one's kind of important
because the whole idea here is to try and do some mobility
drills, like a little bit of stretches.
You know nothing that makes us sweat, but just enough to get
the blood flow flowing. And boosting the oxygen to the
brain is the key here. So take a brisk walk, just go
out and stretch it out a little. The point here being that we
will be sitting in our harnesses for the next few hours and
before we sit in those positions, we have to be
comfortable so that we don't have any pains and niggles or
cramps coming up later on in the flight.
And this is something that I've thought about multiple times
because in conventional sport, there's a whole warm up routine
that we do before we go out and play on the pitch.
But in paragliding, it's just like, yeah, sit in the car, show
up to the take off, strap in and go for it.
And it can get pretty physical depending upon how the
conditions are. But anyways, coming back to the
topic, the 4th 1, which is kind of an optional thing to do, I
would say, because it depends on the person and how much they are
into this. I like to call this as a focus
ritual. You know, spending anywhere
between 5 to 10 minutes. This could be a quiet meditation
pose or some sort of a visualization.
Like you could picture your take off the first thermal or the
transition lines that you're chasing or the challenges that
you might face in mid flight or even your final touchdown.
Like the whole idea is to mimic the visualization in your brain
to suppress the distractions and activate the prefrontal cortex
so that we are able to tell our mind that this is what's coming
and and we should be ready for it in the best possible sense.
Now, I understand that visualization is a topic which
can be dived deep into solely on a whole different level.
And for that, the next week's episode that I'm going to do is
specifically on how to visualize properly.
So stay tuned for that one. But now moving on, this works
wonders for me. And again, I would call this as
an optional take because it depends on the person.
Now what I personally like to do is, and, and there's a little
bit of science behind this as well, is that taking a short
nap, like a 15 to 20 minute nap. But bear in mind that they
should not be closer than two to three hours before the event.
And the idea here is that there's a build up of adenosine.
Basically, adenosine is something similar to melatonin,
and it helps us go to sleep. So The thing is, as soon as you
wake up, there is a gradual buildup of this thing.
I don't want to get into the details because then we'll go
off track here, but the point here is to clear the sleep
pressure that has been built up until that time of the day and
to reset with clarity. But the key here again is to
first of all, have enough buffer time so that you're not able to
overdo it. Because otherwise there's a
chance that some people might wake up groggy if you sleep
longer or for if some reason, you just take a lot more longer
to get back into the activation of your systems right away after
you wake up. So with that, I think I can sum
this whole thing up into something known as a synthetic
morning routine, I would say, where the first thing that
matters is getting some light into your eyes, followed by
correct amount of hydration and snacking, and then a little bit
of movement like limbering up to get in the zone.
And then the 4th one, for which I said I'm going to dive deeper
into the next week when I come out with the episode on
visualization especially is a bit of mental preparation
ritual. And then the fifth one is again,
an optional 1 is the nap reset, but this has to be done at least
two to three hours before the event, which is a bit different
considering that the other routines have to be done
somewhere between an hour and a half to two before the event.
So now before we wrap up for the day, I would like to give you
some insights from some of the elite, at least that I've known
over the period of time. Because back home in India, I
used to play hockey at a fairly decent level.
I mean, you know, I never really got to play for the country
itself, so never wore the colours.
But we still had quite a few professionals working with us,
telling us what to do and how to do.
But let's say that if you're travelling for a competition and
we have the matches that are going to be played at that venue
at 5:00 PM in the evening. So for a few months in advance,
or let's say a few weeks, I mean, probably the professionals
who are aiming for the Olympic levels are doing this months in
advance. Like the whole idea is that if a
sprinter has this event at the Olympics scheduled for 8:00 PM,
then what they will do is that they will start training for
that race every day at 8:00 PM rather than having their regular
schedule of training at 4:00 AM. Or like, you know, I mean,
that's a weird number, but let's say 10 AM or 11:00 AM.
So the idea is to match your entire circadian rhythm to the
competition times. Now, the key here is that of
course you would say that, hey, in paragliding everything is
when the thermals start because that is when the day starts.
So there's no set point of time when there's a start gate
opening. But what we can do is, for
example, let's say I'm going to Macedonia in a week and there's
going to be racing for seven days in a row.
Like even though I'm not a part of the race officially, but I
still hope to be flying in these goggles and learning and
absorbing a lot of it. So my idea here is that if the
start gate in Macedonia is likely to open somewhere around
11:00 everyday, then I want to start doing these rituals and
these pre game checks at least 9:00 beforehand.
So even when I'm not travelling to Macedonia, even if there's a
week that is remaining for me to get on the plane and be a part
of the whole ecosystem over there, I will still start
training my brain to getting into the zone at 9:00 AM.
So that eventually when I get there and it's go time, my brain
is ready to perform at its finest, rather than taking the
first few days to just kind of warm up and absorb the
atmosphere and then adapt to what the reality is.
So the idea is that you visualize the reality that
you're going to face later on, and then your brain adapts to it
much quicker when it actually happens.
And another thing that I would like to point out here is that
from my field hockey days, we were categorically told to avoid
any kind of overstimulation before the match because chasing
adrenaline is going to be there when the event starts anyways.
So the idea is to have very limited emotional or social
triggers or, you know, the caffeine intake, like anything
that gets us in a state of arousal because we're going to
need all of that energy later on when we are performing at the
highest level anyways. So the point was to conserve the
energy as much as possible and up to a point that although
field hockey was a very running heavy sport, you know that we
needed a lower limbs to be in their top shape because there
was a lot of stress and load during the event.
But why I'm trying to tell you this is that we were told to
mostly sit or lie down so that the lactic acid buildup in our
legs is a lot less compared to other teams, which were just
walking around and going on for sightseeing.
And I think this is also visible in some Olympic opening
ceremonies where you would see some teams are skipping the
opening ceremonies because of long standing hours.
And the whole idea is that the fatigue in the lower limbs can
build up over multi hour or multi day events.
So especially in paragliding, let's say if there's a World Cup
which is spread over like 7 days in a row and you will be pushing
bar at 2-3 hours every day, you would want to conserve as much
energy as possible in lower limbs so that by the time it's
day #4 or day #5 you're not risking getting cramps in your
calves or just keeping your muscles as limbered up as
possible. So the point here is to avoid
cumulative fatigue that develops over a period of time.
But anyways, with that, I think we have come to the end of
today's episode and I really hope you found these strategies
useful. Do let me know in comments
wherever you listen to if you have your own little pre fright
rituals or tweaks that we can share with the other audience
members next time onwards. And next week, as mentioned
earlier, we'll dive into how to visualize properly and make it
count when it matters the most. And this Thursday, again, I'm
not going to spill any more beans, but we have a banger of
an episode coming from Battery Lighting Studios, as usual,
coming your way. So stay tuned, stay excited, and
I'll hope you like it.